a central part of Italian culture but
one that's been absent for more than two
months customers ordering lunch at this
Rome restaurants are having to get used
to eating out in a coronavirus world we
feel almost emotional given it's been
two months that would not been out to
eat I'll let you know my opinion once we
finished eating but it is different
we're seated at a distance well after
yell more across Italy not just
restaurants but bars cafes hairdressers
and non food shops can now reopen as
long as social distancing is maintained
they've all been left reeling by the
enforced closure it's abnormal it's a
situation that's a bit apocalyptic if I
can say that because we never thought in
the restaurant business in a historic
center of a European capital that we'd
ever live through something like this
Italy the first country outside Asia to
be overrun by covered 19 went into
national lockdown ten weeks ago to date
it's recorded more than 32 thousand
deaths but the pandemic is also taking a
financial toll Italy's economy is
expected to shrink by nearly 10 percent
this year the government had to concede
to the small businesses to open up the
doors again otherwise the country will
never recover so we are already
envisaging a fall in gross national
products and 20 percent in some
industries it's 90 percent if you go on
this way we'll for sure cure covered but
lose an economy Prime Minister Giuseppe
Conte says the reopening czar a
calculated risk but a major retailors
Association estimates 30 percent of
cafes and restaurants will be staying
shut
Roberta Pepys family restaurant in Rome
is one of them since the lockdown she's
had to pay her three-star from her own
pockets she wants the government to give
people like her help with paying bills
and tax breaks I can't reopen because
this restaurant is like a car in order
to turn it on you need fuel which is the
cash that we do not have and even if we
reopen there wouldn't be enough
customers to cover the costs there are
no tourists and we rely on them tourists
are due to start arriving in Italy early
next month and with new coronavirus
cases at their lowest level since before
the lockdown things seem to be going in
the right direction but here in Milan
famous for its elegant shopping arcades
not everybody's convinced relaxing the
rules will work out nothing will change
everything will return exactly as before
the lockdown will be quickly forgotten
and therefore everything will return as
before we'll go back into an emergency
and a crisis I think corner bus will be
disappear
after time after maybe one month and the
our life would come back normally so for
now many people are cautiously
optimistic but they're all too aware
that if the virus starts to spread
quickly again the new freedoms might
disappear
nadine barber al jazeera